I don't think many people are familiar
with the idea that boredom can be
stressful can you talk a little bit
about that yeah since so many kids are
bored yes and it's certainly profoundly
seen on the on behavior when students
were asked why they're dropping out of
high school the number one response was
boredom and when they were asked to
break it down what do you mean boredom
it would be the subject wasn't
interesting or it would be the
information wasn't relevant to me
so boredom is certainly a problem in
terms of what happened the outcome but
with with boredom and repetition it is
very much like the confinement and lack
of choice that stresses animals put in
cages or people put in prisons or
confined against their will
the brain is a searching surviving
structure that's that is out to explore
and make sense of the world and to be
able to respond to input and when
there's lack of choice that sense of
confinement is frightening it's
threatening and it threatens this sense
of survival so the brain goes on high
alert the stress goes up the lower brain
gets to be in charge and as I said that
neural networks conducting with
neuroplasticity
they've gets more and more efficient
wiring of the system into the lower
brain and disconnect from the upper
brain boredom reflex like a global
judgment that you don't think there's
information to be gleaned from the
environment so it's better to ramp down
the energy you're expending the
environment but what's really
interesting is the act of being bored
itself creates stress on the brain
because your brain doesn't want to be
bored it's like seeking out information
and so that stress is going to compel
you to act to try to solve that problem
which in a classroom usually looks like
disruption or other kinds of things but
so we have this this kind of really
terrible place wherein when you design
on average
right you create situations where kids
that fall behind get stressed from that
which then impairs their ability to
learn but the kids that could keep
moving and are fine are actually held
back and they're bored which creates
stress which has an impairment on
learning so we've got these environments
that are really serving nobody